You're working like mad to
get your bachelor's degree.
You know,
when you're really excited
about the day that I do curse.
Okay,
what happens the week after?
What happens the week after is that you're
no longer in the pursuing a bachelor
degree universe.
You're now in the post bachelor degree
looking for a job universe and that might
not be nearly as pleasant to place.
So the problem is,
is when you attain a goal,
the framework within which you are
operating disappears and there's no
necessary,
there's no necessity that it's
replaced by a better friend.
In fact,
lots of times it's replaced by chaos
at least for some period of time.
So it's really weird thing.
And this is like the surface story.
It's like,
well,
it says office might be happy when
he's rolling the rock up the hill.